5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS "THE FIVE".
THIS IS "THE FIVE"
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
THE REPUBLICANS ARE FED UP WITH
ADAM SCHIFF'S SECRET IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS.
NOW THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
FURIOUS REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMEN
FOUGHT BACK BY STORMING BACK
WITH THE LATEST WITNESS.
REPUBLICANS ALSO HAMMERING
DEMOCRATS WITH A TOTAL LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY.
>> BEHIND THOSE DOORS THEY
INTEND TO OVERTURN THE RESULTS
OF AN AMERICAN PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
WHAT IS ADAM SCHIFF TRYING TO
HIDE?
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS NOT
FAIR.
>> THERE'S NO REASON THIS SHOULD
BE DOWN IN A TINY ROOM WITHIN A
REASON IN THE BASEMENT OF THE
CAPITOL.
THAT'S SO ADAM SCHIFF CAN
CONTROL THE NARRATIVE, DRIVE
POLLING AND CAN GET THE VOTE
THAT HE WANTS, WHICH IS TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: ALL THAT ISHAPPENING
WHILE THE MEDIA EATS UP THE
TALKING POINTS.
CHECK OUT THIS.
THE PRESS REPEATING THAT THE
TESTIMONY WAS DEVASTATING AND
CLEAR EVIDENCE OF A
QUID PRO QUO.
>> UP AHEAD, MORE ON THIS
DEVASTATING DAY FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> IT'S DEVASTATING TESTIMONY.
>> REALLY DEVASTATING PIECE OF
EVIDENCE.
>> THAT'S WHY THE TESTIMONY WAS
SO DEVASTATING.
>> IT'S DEVASTATING.
>> DEVASTATING FROM A NATIONAL
SECURITY PERSPECTIVE.
>> HIS TESTIMONY IS DEVASTATING.
>> SOUNDS LIKE A QUID PRO QUO
DIRECTED BY THE PRESIDENT.
>> IS IN FACT A QUID PRO QUO.
>> TO PUSH FOR A QUID PRO QUO.
>> THERE WAS IN FACT A QUID PRO
QUO.
>> THE VERY CLEAR QUID PRO QUO.
>> THAT IS A QUID PRO QUO.
>> Jesse: NOT SO FAST.
REPUBLICANS IN THE ROOM SAY THE
DIPLOMAT CRUMBLED UNDER
QUESTIONING AND THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF A QUID PRO QUO.
JUAN, DON'T YOU THINK THIS WOULD
CLEAR EVERYTHING UP IF THEY DID
IT IN OPEN?
>> RIGHT.
IT WOULD BE A LEGITIMATE
PROCESS.
>> Jesse: WHY NOT?
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO LIBEL
SOMEBODY.
WHAT IF THEY SAY --
>> Jesse: YOU THINK IT WOULD BE
ILLEGITIMATE TO HOLD A PUBLIC IN
HEAR SOMETHING.
>> NO.
YOU DIDN'T ASK ME THIS.
YOU SAID THIS IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY IS BEING DONE IN PRIVATE
TO ALLOW PEOPLE CONFIDENTIALITY,
MAKE STATEMENTS AND BROUGHT
FORWARD.
BY THE WAY, QUID PRO QUO, HOW
CAN YOU NOT -- DID YOU READ WHAT
BILL TAYLOR SAID?
A WESTPOINT GRAD THAT SERVED IN
VIETNAM, A PUSH APPOINTEE AND
AMBASSADOR IN AFGHANISTAN?
YOU THINK HE'S A LIAR?
>> Jesse: I READ HIS OPENING
STATEMENT.
WHAT WE DIDN'T HEAR IS HIM UNDER
CROSS EXAMINATION.
THAT'S WHAT EVERYBODY WANTS TO
KNOW.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO -- THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF A QUID PRO QUO.
GUESS WHAT?
WE DON'T -- WE CAN'T EVEN PROVE
THAT.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE ANY PEOPLE
ASKING QUESTIONS IN PUBLIC.
>> HERE'S HIS STATEMENT.
YOU CAN READ IT, JESSE.
IN THE STATEMENT --
>> Jesse: ANYBODY CAN MAKE A
STATEMENT AND ANYBODY CAN FAIL
TO ANSWER A FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
WHICH HE DID.
>> YOU THINK TAYLOR IS A LIAR
AND --
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE IS.
I KNOW I DON'T KNOW AND YOU
DON'T EITHER.
>> THE PRESS -- THE PRESS IS
WRONG --
>> Jesse: I KNOW THEY'RE CALLING
PEOPLE IN SECRET AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE LEAKING TO IT "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
>> I CAN READ --
>> Jesse: JUAN, YOU SHOULD BE
ASHAMED FOR DOING THIS BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
>> I'M PROUD THAT THE PRESS OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA CAN
REPORT ON A LEGITIMATE
DISTINGUISHED DIPLOMAT --
>> Jesse: IT'S ALL LEAKS, JUAN.
YOU KNOW IT.
>> Greg: THE THING IS THE
PROBLEM WITH THE SECRET
TESTIMONY IS NOBODY SHOULD
BELIEVE IT.
IT'S -- RIGHT AFTER THE BAT IT
STINKS.
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT, ALL YOU
NEED TO KNOW IS YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF A QUESTION.
YOU HAVE HISTORICALLY LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT.
6.4 MILLION NEW JOBS A BOOM
BEING ECONOMY.
SO FAR YOU HAVE PEACE AND IT'S
CONTAGIOUS, JUAN.
SO WHAT DOES THE ESTABLISHMENT
WANT IN A SECRETLY A NONE MUSCLY
DRIVEN COUP WHICH IS EGGED ON BY
THE MEDIA.
TO YOUR POINT, THAT'S THE THING
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THERE'S ONE EXPLANATION FOR
THIS.
BECAUSE OF THE RESULTS OF
TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE SO FAR, THEY
REALIZE THEY CAN'T BEAT HIM, SO
THEY NEED TO ELIMINATE HIM.
SO WHAT THEY'RE DOING, THEY'RE
WILLING TO DIVIDE AND CREATE
DIVISION AMONG OUR COUNTRY AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON TO SOLVE THEIR
POLITICAL HUMILIATION.
I HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR
LIBERTARIANS, FOR LEFTISTS, TRUE
LEFTISTS.
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHOSE
PRIMARY GOAL IS NOT SPILLING
ANYMORE BLOOD ANYWHERE.
WHERE ARE YOU?
THIS IS THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
FOREIGN POLICY I'VE SEEN IN MY
LIFE.
YOU GOING TO LITTLE HILLARY
CLINTON OR CNN AND ADAM SCHIFF
BASICALLY REPLACE HIM WITH A
HILLARY POD BECAUSE THEY DON'T
LIKE HIM?
AFTER WHAT HE'S DOING?
THAT'S PRETTY FRICKING CRAZY.
>> Jesse: DANA WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYS
DEMOCRACY DIES IN THE DARKNESS.
>> Dana: THE ARGUING FOR
TRANSPARENCY IS USUALLY YOUR
BEST ARGUMENT WITH THE MEDIA.
WE REVERE THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
RIGHT?
SO THE TRANSPARENCY THING IS
GOOD.
THE STUNT TODAY OF -- THE
PRESIDENT SAID I WANT THE
REPUBLICANS TO GET TOUGHER.
THEY'LL WIN THE NEWS CYCLE ON
THAT TODAY.
THEY'LL DRIVE THE NEWS.
BUT WHEN THE MAJORITY OF THE
HOUSE, DEMOCRATS, HAVE THE
GAVEL, THEY'RE NOT AFFECTED BY
THE TRANSPARENCY.
THEY KEEP ROLLING DOWN.
UNTIL THEY SEE SOMETHING IN
THEIR POLLING OR IN THEIR FOCUS
GROUPS OR THE PRESSURE FROM
THEIR CONSTITUENTS GETS TO A
FEVER PITCH ON TRANSPARENCY,
THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
CHANGE IT.
THE OTHER THING IS, I THINK -- I
FEEL LIKE THE GOAL POSTS FROM
BOTH SIDES ARE MOVING SO MUCH
THAT EVEN IF THERE WAS -- THERE
WAS A QUID PRO QUO, I'M SURE IT
WOULD BE LIKE OH, OKAY.
FINE.
>> Greg: WHO CARES.
>> Dana: AND --
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE DO,
DANA, CORRECT?
>> Dana: WHAT?
>> Greg: LIKE I WANT YOU TO
CHECK OUT YOUR CORRUPTION BEFORE
WE GIVE YOU ALL OF THIS MONEY.
THAT'S WHAT HIS JOB IS.
>> BUT GREG, THE QUID PRO QUO
HERE IS SOMETHING FOR THE
PRESIDENT, SOMETHING OF VALUE,
DIRT ON HIS POLITICAL OPPONENT.
>> Greg: THE CORRUPTION -- NO,
NO, NO.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CORRUPTION.
2016 CORRUPTION.
LOOK INTO IT.
>> NO, JOE BIDEN --
>> Jesse: JUAN, THERE'S NO QUID
PRO QUO BECAUSE THE UKRAINIANS
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT ANY OF THE
MONEY WAS BEING HELD.
I WANT TO PLAY SOME SOUND FROM
THE REPUBLICANS ON THIS AND YOU
CAN REACT.
>> THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
REPORTING THAT HE PROVIDED
EVIDENCE OF A QUID PRO QUO
INVOLVING MILITARY AID IS FALSE.
NEITHER HE OR ANY OTHER WITNESS
HAS PROVIDED TESTIMONY THAT THE
UKRAINIANS WERE AWARE THAT
MILITARY AID WAS BEING WITHHELD.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A QUARTERBACK
WITH NO QOU.
>> THE TWO MINUTES, JOHN
RADCLIFF DESTROYED THIS WITNESS.
THERE'S NO QUID PRO QUO.
>> Jesse: DR. SAPPHIRE?
>> I FINED IT INTERESTING, WE
DIDN'T DO THE TIME LINE.
THEY HAVE THE PHONE
CONVERSATION.
TRUMP AND ZELENSKY IN JULY.
THERE'S REPORTS THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS HOLDING BACK THE FUNDS.
THE FUNDS WEREN'T GOING TO BE US
YOKED TILL OCTOBER UNTIL
ZELENSKY MADE A PUBLIC
DECLARATION.
WHICH NEVER HAPPENED.
THE FUNDS DID GO THERE.
I HAVE QUESTIONS WHEN IT COMES
TO THE QUID PRO QUO.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY MY QUESTIONS ARE
NOT BEING ANSWERED.
ADAM SCHIFF IS RIGHTING A TIGHT
SHIP WITH THE CLOSED DOOR POLICY
THAT HE'S ALLOWING THE LEAKS,
ALLOWING THIS NARRATIVE TO BUILD
UP LIKE INFLATED VERBIAGE AND IT
CONTINUES TO DIVIDE THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS THEIR NUMBER 1 GOAL,
MASSIVE DIVISION NOR 2020
ELECTION.
I'M TIRED OF THIS POSTURING JUST
FOR ELECTION PURPOSES.
>> Jesse: I THINK, JUAN, AFTER A
WHILE, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THIS IN THE DARK
IN SECRET SO THE COUNTRY CANNOT
WHY THE PRESIDENT IS BEING
IMPEACHED, PEOPLE WILL BE FED UP
WITH IT.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO DO
LONG-TERM DAMAGE HERE.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHY THE
PRESIDENT IS BEING IMPEACHED?
>> Jesse: YOU CAN'T HAVE ANY
EVEN SEEN BY REPUBLICANS.
THEY CAN'T SEE TRANSCRIPTS.
NEAR THREATENING TO WITHHOLD
CHECKS FROM PEOPLE TESTIFYING.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHY THE
PRESIDENT IS BEING IMPEACHED?
>> Jesse: YOU WANT TO SEE THE
FULL EVIDENCE.
YOU WANT TESTIMONY --
>> IT'S A LEGITIMATE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS THAT THEY
WOULD HOLD --
>> Jesse: YOU THINK IT'S
LEGITIMATE TO DO IT BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Jesse: YOU THINK THIS IS
LEGITIMATE?
>> I JUST TOLD YOU I DO.
THE SECOND THING THAT WILL COME
OUT AND YOU'LL SAY OH, MY GOSH.
WHY ARE THEY PRESENTING IT THIS
WAY?
THIS IS UNFAIR TO THE
PRESIDENT --
>> Jesse: WHEN WILL IT COME OUT?
>> IN A MONTH OR SO.
IT'S THE SENATE THAT SHOULD BE
WORRYING YOU.
RIGHT NOW THE DAILY CALL OR
SOMEBODY DID A POLL OF ALL THE
PEOPLE IN THE SENATE.
FORGET THE POLL OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT THINK THIS IS
LEGITIMATE.
THERE WERE ONLY SEVEN SENATORS
THAT SAID THEY'RE NOT OPEN TO
THE INQUIRY, IMPEACHING --
>> Jesse: DO I LOOK
>> Jesse: DO I LOOK WO
>> Jesse: DO I LOOK WORR
>> Jesse: DO I LOOK WORRY
>> Jesse: DO I LOOK WORRIE
>> Jesse: DO I LOOK WORRIED?
DANA, WHERE IS THIS GOING?
>> Dana: SCHIFF WILL KEEP
CALLING THE WITNESSES.
EACH SIDE THINKS THEY'RE
WINNING.
THERE ARE REPUBLICANS THAT THINK
YOU IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP --
IMPEACHMENT DOES NOT MEAN HE
WON'T BE PRESIDENT ANYMORE.
CLINTON WAS IMPEACHED AND HIS
POLLING NUMBERS WENT UP.
HIS POPULARITY WENT UP.
PROBABLY HAD A CHANCE TO RUN FOR
A THIRD TERM, WHO KNOWS WHO
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THERE ARE REPUBLICANS THAT
BELIEVE THIS IS HELPING HIM.
THEN THERE ARE DEMOCRATS THAT
THINK THAT THEY HAVE TO DO THIS
HE IN ORDER TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THEIR BASE WHO IS
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THEY SAY HOW
ARE YOU HOLDING THE PRESIDENT
ACCOUNTABLE?
MEANTIME, THERE'S REPORTING
TODAY THAT PELOSI'S TEAM AND THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE ARE STILL
WORKING ON THEIR PLANS, WHATEVER
YOU THINK ABOUT THE LOWERING OF
THE DRUG PRICES, THEIR POLICY
PROPOSAL, BUT THEY'RE STILL
MOVING FORWARD ON THAT AND THE
TRADE DEAL, THE USMCA IS STILL
ON TRACK AS WELL.
MAYBE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THEY
CAN GET THINGS DONE AND CONTINUE
WITH IMPEACHMENT.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
WALKING AND CHEWING GAME AT THE
SAME TIME?
>> Dana: A GREAT CLICHE'.